i want to start with congratulations on
the movie sincerely um after knives out
the gray man and ghosted is it in your
contracts you will only work together
going forward look as long as she'll
have that's what chris wants you know
what i mean
she's the first person i go to and if
she says no then we explore the pool but
but she's the first up i just get texts
now are you busy what are you up to
you want to make a movie
what was the memorial service like for
your iphone 6
brutal i still miss it and you know what
i have not even wanted to post this
i feel like my new phone is too heavy
and i know that makes me like the oldest
dinosaur in the world but the problem is
it's right it's right here it's ready
i'm gonna i'm gonna talk some [ __ ] right
now because as i hold it you use the
pinky to like brace it and it feels too
heavy it's too heavy am i the only guy i
got a line here like it's too heavy like
i i need something well so you're saying
pardon me for sentences you're saying
captain america can't lift an iphone all
right now now you're getting aggressive
now you're trying to get clickbait now
you're trying to make waves i'm just
saying do i miss the home button yeah i
do i missed the home button the home
button was [ __ ] awesome yeah but then
i had a thousand people like get the sc
i'm like no i i don't want i want the
iphone 6. i want something from before
to work until it doesn't work anymore
and i don't want apple to be well i
don't want to okay jumping into the next
thing um you guys have done a lot of
different projects if someone has
actually never seen anything that either
of you have done what is the first thing
you want them watching and why
maybe the best for you is it marilyn i
mean like maybe it's something we
haven't even seen yet because let's be
honest anna's
so good in knives out i mean that really
is the thing that everybody like she she
kicked the doors down with knives didn't
she
but but
maybe the best thing is yet to come
maybe is it in the maryland what would
you pick would you take what would you
do i would start with knives out would
you yeah and then say but wait
i can also do this and then watch this
sure sure what about you oh for me yeah
that's right um you know i did a movie
called sunshine a long time ago that was
really i enjoyed with danny boyle and i
really like snow piercer and look i mean
i'm i'm i i got a lot of love for the
marvel world so winter soldier was
something to me that i really was like
wow that's that's exactly how i wanted
that to go so maybe winter soldier uh
this movie has nine action set pieces in
it it's
it's wall-to-wall action you guys are
part of those action sequences i'm for
people that aren't familiar with the way
movies are made what which what do you
wish more people knew about actually
making an action scene in a movie like
this
i mean i think i think the time that it
takes to shoot just
you know
the simplest thing that maybe is on
screen for two minutes it would take two
weeks
like the
right yeah like the scale of the you
know the complexity of like putting
together not you know
all the actors and the elements and the
the the locations or whether it's the
studio on the blue screen or whatever
like making it all work at once and
matching to
you know each other's
energy and what
characters and all of that is just it's
very
very complex and and the toll that that
takes on you is really exhausting and
you're
you're
yeah yeah
i mean it's the repetition i mean i
don't know beyond this movie on and i
just did another movie together but and
in that movie it required this you know
constant repetition and and it's one
thing if the scene itself only requires
a
moment of action the the entire setup
and the entire moment is dedicated to
one quick punch but if that one quick
punch also incorporates a little sliver
of humanity or comedy or a little ribbon
of something authentic that also you
know elevates the action to something
more relatable that you have to repeat
those things over and over and over
again it's the repetition it's the fact
that you're going to be doing the same
thing
from a thousand angles a thousand times
and
you can't you can't take one take off
because every single take matters also
not because it's cold and you want to
wear jackets
you should because then you're doing all
the action and you're sweating and dying
overheating
so yeah it's better just to keep it
light and put a jacket on when you're
not shooting
you